time now for one more thing rush
limbaugh made a very surprise
announcement on his radio program today
and he told his listeners that he's just
been diagnosed with advanced lung cancer
listen my intention is to come here
every day I can I've had so much support
from family and friends during this that
it's it's just it's it's been tremendous
and our thoughts and prayers go out to
El Rush bo he said that he's going to be
taking a few days off during the times
when he's gonna be undergoing treatment
but not every day
it'll be on and off for the next couple
weeks so ever long it takes to get
better and we wish rushed the best yeah
I mean I I don't I can't think of
anybody who's been a bigger influence in
in conservative thought and the person
the type of person who was able to
bridge the intellectual right of buckley
to the common man i remember when it
started in the 80s there was nothing
like it late 80s and there's nothing
nothing like him it's phenomenon yep he
really is KT giant yeah I would say he's
a giant as jayna just said he was a pet
he's been a pioneer and he's never
backed down from a fight so I wish him
well and I hope that his treatment is
successful yes speedy recovery they had
such an in-depth knowledge of history I
saw him giving a speech one time when it
got an award and it was just amazing all
the things that he knew and how much he
truly loves America and it that
transferred to his viewers listeners in
his viewers yeah and I just want to say
you know sometimes Russia and I had big
differences but rush was always so kind
I think sometimes his humanity escapes
it in a moment like this rush I just
want you to know that people across the
aisle wish you the best you're a good
man